I am British I am British I'm British
I'm British I am British I'm British
[Music]
why am I nervous nervous I'm nervous too
I'm actually a dual citizen uh us and UK
I um grew up in England in London and I
moved to America when I was 12. so
you'll hear I have a bit of a like funky
accent I'm not a dual citizen I'm a
citizen of the UK but I also moved when
I was 12. and my accent for the most
part I think I still sound kind of
British yeah yeah I'm a citizen of the
UK um I spent about four years in India
so I got a bit of that as well and I
moved to the US two years ago for UCLA
so I'm a student right now I'm also a
citizen of the UK I moved to the US two
months ago I lived in Canada before that
for four years which was horrible
because I hate the cold
um I've lived here for 11 years I'm from
Liverpool
um
um yeah I've been here a long time so my
accent
kind of sounds modeled where I miss Gaza
I'm also a deal citizen
um I moved here when I was 12.
uh well I got my ideal citizenship when
I was 12. well so if people got their
dual citizenships at 12. suspicious
I said it first that's true that's true
you're from London right in the UK yeah
London London Leicester Liverpool where
are you from London or London I'm from
Manchester what part of London no way
okay I'm from upper Norwood yeah we're
specifically West Western yeah I'm from
Leicester and wigston okay nice we're in
Liverpool I studied there um I was I was
born in West Derby okay um
Market Harborough
sounds familiar yeah I mean I grew up in
a very small bubble I mean my parents
would take me everywhere
um and I grew up in India for like 14 to
18. and then go back to the UK finish up
my school there how long were you in
Leicester for zero to 14 was born in
Alaska yeah that's cool I feel like
someone from Leicester would have
automatically known where Market Harbor
is I'm from Manchester and I know where
Market Harbor is a tiny little town I
don't know a lot about English geography
because I was so in my own world and
yeah my parents would take me around
everywhere so his story was convincing
to me because that's similar to my story
well you guys's first impressions of
America really overwhelmed
the imperial system oh yes
horrible well I've been here for two
months I'm still trying to get used to
Fahrenheit it's really stressing me out
the the temperature is one things like
that you know and like I work off a
24-hour clock yeah yeah yeah I still got
that I think tipping culture is
pretty bad oh everything yeah everything
whatever the price is it's like at least
Freedom we could save this conversation
page I got a lot of questions like
people assume because you're British you
like something so when One Direction was
big they're like you're British you like
One Direction I was like I have heard
maybe two of their songs or like Harry
Potter hot take I haven't seen all of
the movies I've only seen like two
you're joking I'm sorry I know
I know like a British thing and I
haven't done it well like the first
thing they say is like talk about tea or
yeah
they always say say water or like pip
pip cheerio like sorry no one says that
[Music]
his story at first kind of seemed like
he was just making something up
you're the worst British accent I've
heard ever I'm so convinced to
because he didn't know his geography
I was just shocked I was a bit sheltered
but so I didn't know my geography very
well but I was wondering when they're
gonna get Michael out
I feel like when I meet people they
always say oh you're from London they
automatically like they assume
everyone's from London I'm like no I'm
from Liverpool they're like oh The
Beatles and they mentioned the Beatles
but the UK is so big like they just
think it's just like it's funny because
I feel like a fake when I say I'm from
London because it's like oh of course
you're from London I spoke to someone
that thought London was the country
of one time someone asked me are you
from England or Britain yeah yeah well
that's because Americans don't know
geography at all I will say since living
here I have felt my just general World
Knowledge declining education
about anywhere anymore for me since I
moved when I was 12 which is uh seventh
grade here in the states she mentioned
seventh grade and usually we say year
seven or year eight or year nine and it
just threw me off the biggest change I
noticed was how students address their
teachers like it's very informal you
know whereas I think growing up in
England like you would never question
your teacher you know or like I feel
like the parents have that kind of
it was funny because obviously growing
up in England
um you wear uniforms all the time yeah
it was Lavender in the summertime with
white socks winter summer uniform and a
pea uniform that changes based ones
all the thinking about it like I feel
like I'm so glad that we had a uniform
in school because the poor fashion
choices I made at 13. I'm so glad I
didn't have to go to school dress like
no genuinely I look back at my Facebook
photos and want to disassociate from
wherever that goal was it wasn't really
hey good humans it's Timmy here and
Maddie uh I'm a sucker for a good
British accent do you think you've
sniffed out the mole yet honestly I'm
not sure all I've been smelling are
these sweet sweet fragrances I got from
semper Sanford what's that wait you've
never heard of scentbird well sepbert is
actually the sponsor of this portion of
the video scentbird is reimagining
everything about how people discover
shop for purchase and even experience
fragrances they let you try new designer
fragrance every month for just 17 and
every month you get to pick what you
want to receive so there aren't any
surprises here try this that bird has a
huge selection of perfumes colognes and
unisex options and with each fragrance
you'll get a 30 day supply so you can
try out fragrances before committing to
a full-size bottle which can easily cost
over 150 this month I received Memoirs
wish you were here and I love it because
the notes of Summer Rain toasted almonds
and fresh ground coffee just give me the
Cozy Vibes of chilling in a cafe on a
rainy summer day so good this is throne
from English Laundry it has both floral
and fruity notes and you know how much I
love my fruity notes but it also has
that mask vibe that you get with a lot
of cologne oh my God I love that my
boyfriend's getting that one for sure um
excuse me I'm keeping this one for
myself no no you can actually use the
coupon code jubilee55 to get 55 off your
first month at Sanford it's just a
little over eight dollars for your first
month available in the USA and Canada be
sure to check out the links in the
description for all the scents we
received this month thanks so much to
semper for sponsoring this video now
let's get back into the episode
she was a little bit quieter than the
rest of the group
oh my gosh you guys did good you guys
are good I think I said grade seven
there are words that I say in the
American way now raise your hand if you
think the mole is still in the box and
you'd wish to continue the game
all right majority rules that means we
move on to round three so you guys still
think the mole's in the box right now
who do you think it is
I thought you guys were all British like
I really was ready to honestly ready to
Winston pick up on some accent glitches
I'm just a really suspicious person
generally okay if you had to pick one
item from the supermarket what was it
like your favorite item from that store
so chocolate fingers
hey this is a really random thing to say
about the meal the Tesco meal oh my God
yes so they're always the best I
ironically bear with these it came in a
yellow package it was like an American
pancake and it was so good you put it in
the toaster and I put it in the toast
all the time it was really tasty it was
just legendary I think
but it wasn't yeah it wasn't something
notable what would you get the prawn
cocktail sandwich definitely oh no I
like this crisp the porn pink one I
think the crisps I missed the most are
Monster Munch and Quavers I was gonna
say Quavers what's it crinkle cut cheesy
what's it no I don't think
what about discos do you guys like
discos
they're not here at all he didn't know
what discos were I mean okay well he
can't be British my initial suspicions
what I don't know just out of everybody
it's probably my accent I think also too
you were the only one who didn't raise
your hand I really thought because I
thought you guys were good I was like
okay these are my fellow Brits right and
then you said I thought you all were
British there were just some things no
one has that much British camaraderie
I'm not saying it is you okay I'm just
saying out of everyone who it could have
been in my mind okay it was closer to
the baby I'd rather not say so now you
look suspicious
I don't trust anyone you could all be
lying to me if it's any I mean I don't
know if this is cheating but I literally
have a tattoo on my body of my postcode
[Music]
he didn't know what disco chips were
you mother
yeah okay he knows you know I'm really
bitter about being voted out just
because somebody doesn't know the same
snack as you does not mean that their
nationality should be questioned if you
think the mole is still in the box and
you'd like to continue the game raise
your hand but oh God
uh I still feel she might be them all
really
I'm really like
I mean I guess continue okay so you got
your dual citizenship when you were 12
did you move with your family and where
did you move to I got sponsored by my
aren't you sponsors yeah we've got
sponsored from when we were really young
so pretty much when we're born by the
time it came through that was a waiting
list back then so it came through when
we're 12. when we were kids we used to
come every year my mom wanted us to move
you know or have the option when we're
ordered to be able to go back and forth
you know I've been here for 11 years I
came in 2012 and I originally came over
to see my sister she lives in North
Carolina she has her own little Deli so
I was helping her out and then in 2014 I
moved to LA and I've been here since
yeah your turn okay I know I you guys
are like ganging up on me my dad works
at an IT company and so they asked if he
could be the manager in LA and we all
moved and we've been here for 12 years
okay went to school here you said you go
UCLA yeah I go to UCLA I'm studying
linguistic anthropology
minoring in French
I don't know linguistics you think yeah
do you know a lot about football like do
you know any of the teams in the Premier
League well okay I never got into
football really when I was there I only
supported the teams that my friends
which ones what teams so obviously
Chelsea Arsenal man you were like the
main ones I don't watch sports in
general really
um if a game's aren't if the World Cup's
on obviously you're watching England all
the way but I don't really watch too
much at football but if you grow up in
England you'll know about the Premier
League yeah no gosh this is hard
[Music]
I had a feeling
guys are wrong I think they'd made a
pact and I was just the only one not in
that pack do you feel confident in your
choice I do
definitely
yeah
okay good
if the lights turn green that means that
you have voted them all out and you both
win if the lights turn red that means
the mole is still in the box and you
lose
so
if you did you did a good job yeah
nothing to worry about
three
two one
[Music]
look the mole reveal themselves
in three two one
[Applause]
are you kidding me that was my first
pick man I mean I got it from the get-go
you knew it was contagious and you
continued to play I told you it's all
about the dineros yo I studied but not
not the geography I was looking at the
map but I didn't recognize uh all the
places and I could always do somewhat of
a British accent or at least I thought I
could and then I just Googled like
where's the most amount of brown people
and I was like Lester lesser it is your
accent was really good I was like I had
some somewhat of a plan but not knowing
geography is pretty American so I'm
pretty sure yeah flabbergasted
you probably sounded more British than
me I guess I have a joke I'm not sure
it's very funny uh but what would you
call my leaving the box in the first
round
brexit
sorry that was all that was all I could
think about when I left I was like oh my
God this is yeah anyway
[Music]
there's some more in there yo